today is the Battle of the YouTube Heavy
way Zack King fras rug and Sydney Morgan
go head-to-head in a sandwich making
frenzy I'm being set up for a disaster
here I would literally cry if I was an
idiot sandwich oh no here at Caesar's
Palace in Las Vegas whoever impresses me
the most will be crowned my idiot
sandwich you guys excited oh yeah Vegas
ready your time starts
now have potato you're quick come on
quick running around I was practicing at
home and I didn't finish so all right uh
so this one's all about hot hot hot and
trust me here in front of Caesar's
Palace it is hot today sandwiches need
heat so this one could be one of the the
most spiciest one of the most delicious
sandwiches across this entire
competition do I own a kitchen yes do I
spend a lot of time there no it's my
first time putting on an apron today and
I I God knows why because where are my
curves why is the bacon stuck together
uh Sydney you good why is my Bacon stuck
together Che it just needs a little bit
of separating stop
complaining rug what all right so we're
starting with the french fries here
we're going to air fry then french fries
in a sandwich of course California style
California Burrito California fries come
on you're going to love it trust me I
hope so right Zach uh so you going down
the uh Bon me going Bon me my son is
Vietnamese he's adopted and so his
favorite food is spa and the sandwich so
this is for him how old is he he's six
now six congratulations congratulations
right two minutes gone sounding good
good luck oh my gosh I'm already
starting off pretty slow I'm not going
to lie we got um we got bacon kabasi we
got adobo chili barbecue sauce we got a
SLO that we're going to pop on top it's
it's going to be fantastic I'm
excited let's go let's go marinating the
meat hinch of chili powder we got to
make it spicy though cooking for Gordon
Ramsay is nerve-wracking but definitely
an honor I don't know if I seasoned this
properly the most I've cooked is top
Ramen so we'll see how this goes how do
I open
these ah oh no she's a little burnt
she's a little burnt this
one this one has to go she's too burnt
she's too
burnt I'm actually scared about Zach
King you know like he pulls a lot of
stuff on you know on his social media he
does like some magic stuff so who knows
what he's going to pull out today I I
wish I had magic that would be amazing
okay where are things at knife there's a
lot of knives here and could I tell you
the difference in like when you're
supposed to be using which one
absolutely not oh also I need bread duh
flip
it oh
yeah okay I'm taking cooking directions
from you here we go I think this is
Serrano or regular let's see it can't be
guac without some spices so okay what do
you think is this good are we
good okay right 5 minutes gone 15
minutes to go 5 minutes are gone oh my
God I don't know how to cook bacon you
don't know how to watch it's getting
burnt so fast why is there so much
juice it's black hold on wait oh God oh
God what I swear it's not done on half
of it but then it's burnt on the other
half it's go it needs to be tossed okay
turn it around right turn it around girl
maybe take out that uh let's get rid of
that fat in there and then we'll get
that nice and sort of crispy let's start
that again yeah yeah yeah let's put that
down there come on Sydney you got this
they told me you were good girl who told
you that they lied they lied come on you
got this well there's couple more strips
it's like when you lie about your like
experience to get the job and then you
get it and it's like oh God we dumped
out the fat because apparently that will
help us chef they had to step in because
it's going that bad I can't find my
tongs here your tongs just W they there
I don't know and the Bus St ah where's
that oh there oh my gosh were they
supposed to be there I'm being set up
for a disaster here what's the what's
the rub on this thing um you like medium
what's the rub not temperature rub I rub
I don't is that the seasoning I don't
cook Gordon
Gordon what is the rub what does that
mean what's the SE on there what's so I
put some olive oil chili powder garlic
salt um onion powder right I just hope
you don't get sick from this I think I
think I'll be good I think I'll be good
you got 12 minutes to go oh that was
nerve-wracking guys I don't even think
the bacon fits in here all right okay
this looks a lot better this is already
looking a lot better right Zach 12
minutes to go coming up to halfway how
you doing okay I'm good I'm going to
make a little spicy mayo sauce that's
going to kind of be the sandwich when I
mentioned the kids you were coming today
um they wanted to talk to about that
broomstick moment oh yeah what were you
thinking about before you did it and did
you think no it's not going to work a
lot of our stuff is just kind of on a
whim right like we just come up with an
idea go out and shoot it we don't know
if it works if there's one person being
tricks to the sandwich is going to be
you right yeah yeah right oh my gosh I'm
sweating this is so scary Sydney are we
good I'm so
good and rug I'm I'm stressed Gordon I'm
stressed hold on how is this looking
guys we're coming to halfway 10 minutes
gone 10 minutes to go come on all right
all right this is so big I'm scared now
I
think got the fries going we got the
guac oh what am I missing okay cheese
onion oh spicy mayo spicy mayo we got to
make it
spicy usually people measure I'm not
much of a direction follower I kind of
you know go off and do my own thing is
that a lot I don't know I would
literally cry if I was an idiot sandwich
what a what an honor that would be kind
of a strange honor right but I would be
stoked a pinch of this oh no that was
not a pinch 9 minutes to go guys come on
9 Minutes ah this is stressful this is
literally going so fast right rugy good
it's a little bit pink is this too pink
or pink is fine kid pink is fine all
never mind I'm good pink is fine all
right we got Chef's approval on that but
uh rug if I was you I would change gear
what what does that mean it means move
your ass okay okay okay let's go come on
Earth to Sydney we good we're so good
I'm I'm not even I'm not even worried
about it Chef Zach is staying composed
he's calm he doing what are you doing
are you frying something I am you're
frying something what are you frying
don't talk to me please I need to walk I
don't know what I'm doing Zach come on
Ro what bread guys what bread what bread
which bread it's a
California where where where is
that I'm I'm just going to do this I'm
going to do the basic I don't know how
to use a can opener okay she's having
trouble with the can opener that's good
this is not working dude is is this too
pink like Gordon said he likes pink but
I don't know if this is too pink why is
my bread not working how we doing the
crowd is getting in my head they're
saying this is too pink uh it is a
little bit pink we can put it back on
there we're going to put it on for sure
yes all it needs is a tail we'll get it
back in the field all right let's go
let's go right uh 4 minutes to go my man
four minutes ago I'm just starting to
put it all together man love that love
that you got the heat in there as well
yep the heat is going to coming right
now love that 4 minutes come on Sydney
come on come on come on for the heat we
are going to drop some peppers on here
what can I put to make this spicier
right now we're putting some jalapeno
there to get the
spice so hopefully it's spicy enough why
am I shaking oh my God why am I shaking
honestly these final seconds can make or
break an amazing hot sandwich think what
do you think do we approve do we approve
next time take the Cucumber the Long Way
throw away the inside of the cucumber
and pick some but it looks great should
I do that now no 15 seconds to go go I
forgot the Tomato I forgot the
Tomato five four stressing 3 2
1 well
done right now for the most exciting
time uh the taste test uh let's start
off with Zach first give us a little
description please okay this is a take
on the Vietnamese Bond me and uh instead
of the mayonnaise and butter it's got a
little spicy ma that looks beautiful I
love that ladies and gent what do you
think oh my goodness me let's get in
there shall we
so M and the heat look at that good one
cheers I love the crunch M you kind hit
you later I love the acid the soundus
Zach it's good yeah well done well
done m
let's go let's go let's go right my man
now describe that please all right so
this is the California heat sandwich we
added some guacamole some bacon some
skirt steak spicy mayo to give that
little kick I added some Jalapenos in
there as well and uh yeah assembled it
all together here for you love that so
it needs a bit more color on the outside
for the bread right absolutely yeah and
do we have another guest coming who's
that for oh hold on hold on okay all
right now we're good presentation's good
now okay great um let's get inside there
because it's all about what's inside
right absolutely so presentation doesn't
matter presentation is
crucial crucial what do we
think I like that I think it's you like
the fries is is there cheese on there or
is there what's in here what what so
okay that's the one thing I did forget
the cheese I'll be honest do you think
cheese is crucial for a sandwich depends
what's in that rug rug rug come on man
have you ever had fries in a sandwich
though yes rug okay I thought I was
creative here all right shall We Ready
Cheers
M it's messy it's juicy and it's
delicious good job thank you good job
appreciate
[Applause]
that oh my goodness me Sydney I hope
that was a good good reaction it looks
great describe that for me please what
am I doing describe it oh
okay tell me what you got so this is the
spicy meat SLE iconic extravaganza 3,000
let's get in there shall we yeah pretty
sure so um that looks good that look
wait a second that looks good wait a
second that look good how does that
look shall we oh my God can we cheers
yeah of course you can so you toasted
the bread as well right yes of course
you wow it's juicy juicy you got the
texture you know the SLO you got the
acidity of the Tomato it's seasoned
beautifully the seasoning yeah m good
it's good go
okay right three amazing sandwiches
cooked by Zach rug and Sydney please you
three step forward the Moment of Truth
our winner
[Music]
is uhoh
uhoh congratulations ghost
[Applause]
to what are you swi louder I'm an idiot
s Jeff
Gordon thank you so much for watching
these amazing idiots Please Subscribe
for more and if you'd like a chance than
grossly invite me then use the hash
idiot
[Applause]
sandwich